quand les équipiers du dernier jugement
se prépare à s'entraîner c'est
généralement dans la bonne humeur et en
toute convivialité mode relax activer le
calme avant la tempête
on se relâche bon c'est juste un
entraînement donc oui c'est un petit
moment de convivialité on se voit on se
prépare on faire attention sur prendre
ses précautions puisque il ya la semelle
il faut vraiment apporter pour ne pas
l'abîmer
le but c'est de pouvoir coup avec il
paraît pas avant une presqu'île au
françois quartier général de l'équipe b
team il tisse une fois par semaine ces
hommes plusieurs fois titré sont de
sortie dans les joues franciscaine
ou quelques semaines avant le lancement
du tour la pression monte monte monte
encore et encore comme pour un ballet de
danse les répétitions son capital afin
d'éviter il faut pas que la polémique a
anticipé le rafale à ne pas quitter
pencher le gard pour après nbc
c'est par là qu'il entend fois ok pas
bout merde ici on se projetait dans la
yole avec les coureurs en plein exercice
et bien cela donnerait sa loge et comme
en plein tour à n'importe quel moment
donné tout basculer d'une attention au
rapport une fois on a fait ça toute la
saison
le tout sous l'oeil attentif du
patriarche une bagnole
chez les hommes c'est jamais le matin
sur la douce toujours les hommes jour j
moins 6 pour l'équipe de laguiole zapper
2010 objectif tenter de ne pas couler
cette année pour récupérer le podium
[Musique]